merci beaucoup madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
vous parlez souvent de République
exemplaire c'est pourquoi je voudrais
vous interroger au sujet d'une situation
qui était là ce loin d'être exemplaire
en effet il s'agit de quelqu'un qui est
champion de France des mises en examen
et qui pourtant continue d'être membre
du cabinet et conseillé du président de
la République Monsieur solaire pour ne
pas le nommer si je vous interroge c'est
que nous savons désormais quand cette
qualité de conseiller du président il a
eu accès à des informations
pourtant censés rester secrète en
provenance du ministère de la Justice
sur une enquête encore en cours or ces
informations ont été transmises ensuite
par Monsieur solaire à celui qui était
visé par l'enquête résultat cette
interférence a permis de protéger un
réseau de trafiquants de drogue depuis
la présidence de la République avec
l'appui de l'un de vos ministères madame
la Première ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour que l'exemplarité que vous
revend généralement ne soit pas qu'un
discours mais se traduisent
véritablement dans les actes